last year we set out to make the best
dungeons and dragons show on the
internet and this year we decided to
make it even better with its second
season on corridordigital.com
in making the second season we've taken
a true leap everything from cutting edge
camera tracking technology to major
motion picture visual effects workflows
all done here in corridor so today i'm
going to give you guys a little peek as
to how this has all come together
we've been following the source of this
mind player hive we need to go deeper i
have a bad feeling about this one of the
biggest improvements of this next season
is truly the storytelling we love to
play d d but not everyone likes to watch
d d which is why this show has been
edited truly like an awesome fantasy
drama you don't need to know rules of
the game and all that stuff it's really
just the best collaborative storytelling
that we can offer
i had a dream tell me on the street deep
below i saw everything i saw all of the
mind players
the story revolves around us four
adventurers you got myself and you also
have jake we have nico and we have d
nico's character nest is a warrior he's
also like a sniper type elf dude these
characters basically d in real life he's
very sinister but in a good way and we
got a bar to the group warren watts
played by none other than jake he's the
glue that keeps all of our characters
together and yeah my character is like a
giant eight foot tall goliath barbarian
i like to smash stuff sam as the dm
plays every npc in the entire game and
it makes the whole gameplay like come
alive this is not gonna feel like you're
just watching some dudes sitting around
a table it's gonna feel like you're
going on an adventure with them
[Music]
so you're probably sick of hearing about
unreal engine 5 at this point but i
can't understate how crucial it's been
to getting this show done we're
digitizing the actual real-life game
boards we're playing d d with by taking
hundreds of detailed photos of them and
then reconstructing them into these
dense super high polygon 3d models we
basically get to drop these in here and
render things out on the fly and it's
incredibly efficient i think we've
created some of the coolest scenes we've
ever done in unreal engine 5.
it's been about a year since i was in
this costume in fact i think it was last
july when we filmed the green screen
photography for season one it was a
great time season one
was ambitious pull out a green screen
and recreate the best moments at the
table playing dungeons and dragons with
our friends as an artist what i love
most in the world is finding novelty
what is like the thing that is new what
is interesting about it because it's new
we had to build a camera tracking
solution because we're dealing with
hundreds of shots and we don't want to
sit and wait while we're manually 3d
tracking all these shots for season one
i made a diy version that was uh it was
okay the problem with season one we
barely could move we maybe slide the
camera a little bit maybe move up season
two
completely different
we got early access to the htc mars
camera tracking solution and it is
incredible a setup like this allows you
to get shots that you could never get if
you were going to track your background
manually i was just whipping the camera
around i was going upside down with the
camera i was running with people across
the green screen we even get a feed
right here as we're filming so we know
what everything's going to look like as
it's shot which completely transforms
how the actors on the green screen get
to perform as well but in order to
really utilize this we're going to need
to build a huge green screen the biggest
green screen in our studio's history to
light a green screen you need a lot of
light and thankfully aperture hooked us
up with a bunch of bright leds that also
change colors that way we can light the
green screen the right color but also
light the actors and immerse them in the
world bringing the world together the
moment that made season two shooting
really stand out to me as a huge
testament to all of the hard work we've
put in over the last year and a half it
was a shot where my character was having
to walk up onto this very thin
footbridge but as ren was climbing the
virtual set we actually laid apple boxes
for him to start climbing by actually
standing up on little apple boxes and
whatnot it raises the floor plane which
allows the camera to go below it this
doesn't seem like much but it changes
everything because now by putting a
bridge in the way of the boxes i'm
actually above the camera we're getting
a more epic shot when i was trying to
get the wide shot of that very moment i
needed to look further down and there
was no more green screen so i asked to
bring a pop-up green screen and toss it
on the floor and boom the environment
appeared at my feet suddenly it's like
the freaking black hole bugs bunny thing
thrown on the ground and you have a
portal into the world we couldn't do
that last year we could do it this year
and we do it many times the best part of
it all is that at the end of the day all
i have to do is go to unreal engine hit
render on our background plates and now
suddenly we have hundreds of green
screen shots filmed on this camera
hundreds of background plates and they
all go straight to fenner for
compositing
the psychic blast comes out
30 points of damage and you're stunned
for a minute so one of the really
awesome and exciting things about the
visual effects of son of dungeon is you
know you're going from all these
different realms these different planes
every shot you're getting something new
and unique there's different monsters
there's different magic effects so it's
been a ton of fun and really you know
challenging but exciting to create these
different visual effects in season one
we had a small very indie team working
on editing and vfx for this season the
team expanded we got more editors and
more vfx artists but that also meant we
had to change the entire vfx workflow
the difference between this season and
what the team did last season with son
of a dungeon is that we are using nuke
to really speed up our workflow we're
able to template out these giant scripts
it basically has all these pre-built
effects and looks that really add a
cinematic quality to the shots with all
of the various technical upgrades to the
show it just allows sam and carmichael
to tell this story in a way that is just
a lot more freeing for them and visual
effects isn't going to be limiting that
this second season of son of a dungeon
is the biggest show that we've ever self
produced and none of it would have been
possible without the subscribers on
corridordigital.com so seriously thank
you for that if you want to see the show
head over to corridor digital.com where
we also have been documenting this
entire process in much greater detail we
would love to know what you think go to
quarterdigital.com right now the first
two episodes are already up right now
and the third one comes out in a few
days i'll be chilling in the comments
live streaming the episodes as they go
up and of course i am looking forward to
hanging out with you there
[Music]
three sheets to the wind three sheets to
the wind
i've been around the world and back
again
three sheets to the wind is where i
begin
until my time comes to an end